this is a production of Cornell
University
thanks so much to dawn and for everybody
here and also in Geneva look at that
turnout in Geneva thank you guys so much
for coming out although I just want to
reiterate something that John said that
this is a truly fabulous award and I
think anybody who has any interest in
doing travel after they graduate or can
think of a project that involves travel
as part of your part of your graduate
education I think it's a really
fantastic opportunity and I was
personally very excited to get this so
I'm also really excited to talk to you
today about my experience in Tasmania so
where are we going we are going to test
media and I'm going to start by
introducing my research a little bit to
give you a little bit about context
about why I even went to Tasmania to
begin with move into an introduction to
Tasmania kind of give you a whirlwind
tour through pictures of the state and
then talk about the research that I did
in tazi and then hopefully at the end
I'll have time for some questions and
the pictures that are accompanying the
slides aren't always completely a
topical about what's on the slide but I
you know it's hard when you have so many
pictures and you want to show off the
beauty of a place so enjoy the pictures
and also try to look at the data that's
on the slides if you can so I'm going to
start off by talking about sour rod and
this is the disease that I work on as
part of my PhD project and when i
arrived at cornell in 2013 sour raw was
a very poorly understood disease we
didn't really understand what caused it
how it spread where it even was in the
world but we did know that it typically
develops on tight cluster thin-skinned
varieties of grapes we start to see a
discoloration starting at about 15
bricks and then really the
characteristic of the disease is that we
smell vinegar really emanating from
these clusters
wounds appear to exacerbate the rod and
then we start to see damaged berries
ooze and we see drosophila or fruit
flies swarming around the clusters and
so far we've seen it in new york ontario
oregon washington california and then
also reports of it in France and
Portugal and you can see here this is a
picture of shower rod on Pinot Noir and
spoiler alert this is from Tasmania so
it turns out I did find it there which
was very good for my research it's a
particularly disgusting picture of sour
rot if you leave it alone and let it do
its thing and I'm sorry for the
horticulturist in the room pathologists
we just love this kind of stuff so this
is truly disgusting examples of sour
rods so some of the questions that I've
asked as part of my PhD research are
what are the identities of the
microorganisms that cause sour rot what
is the epidemiology of the disease what
is the role of vinegar flies or fruit
flies and then also is Sarah rot found
in other cool climate viticultural
regions which is what brings me to Tess
mania so where is Tasmania so I was
asked a lot of times if I was going to
Tanzania and no in fact I did not go to
Africa I went to Australia and so
Tasmania is this nice little state down
here at the bottom of Australia and it
is very much unlike the rest of
Australia in a lot of ways so kind of
form a picture of what you think of
Australia in your mind and then I'll
venture into some pictures and you can
see the contrast it's just a very
different place than the images we have
in our mind of kangaroos bouncing
through you know ayers rock or coolaroo
in the background just a very different
place and so here is the state of of
Tasmania and down at the bottom we have
Hobart which is the capital which is
where I was primarily based and the
other major city in the state is
launceston which is up in the northern
part and I'm going to kind of give you
this is your whirlwind photo tour of the
state so we're going to go in this
counterclockwise fashion and you'll get
to see some beautiful shots of of the
state and hopefully kind of give you a
taste for what Tasmania looks like and
just kind of give you this this feeling
for the place that I tried to get over
my five months there so starting out
just east of Hobart here dhola right is
the type of rock that forms these
amazing formations and it's actually a
type of igneous rock it's made of it was
magma that rose out of the center of the
earth when Tasmania was separating from
gondwana so this was a really amazing
kind of event obviously in the history
of our earth and when Tasmania was one
of the last pieces to break off right
before Antarctica broke off of Gondwana
and when it did these massive formation
literally came out of the center of the
earth and formed these coastline these
rock formations on the coastline that
are like nothing else I've ever seen in
my life just truly phenomenal and just
you know covering these coastlines you
can see them in the background and you
can also hiked out on top of them
there's unlike Tasmania is a state that
I mean it's an island right so water
dominates everything around it but just
this vastness of very few people
actually living there there's only half
a million people on the entire island
and this really vast space and
completely gorgeous beaches you can see
from the white sand beaches that it's
primarily course that has made these
white sands and gorgeous waters now it
is unlike a lot of the rest of Australia
where it is this is cool climate so I
was there in the summer time it did get
hot we were it was a drought year but
you I mean it does get cold when by the
time I left
at the end of May it was down to 33 34
degrees we got a frost I mean it was it
was cold so not really what you'd think
of normally when you think of Australia
so this is the northeastern coast we're
kind of moving up towards launceston at
this point and this is the type of
unbelievable land formations that you
see when you go out hiking mountains and
on also these white sand beaches and
this is the first of a few is mrs. and
that i'm going to show you photos of and
so the kind of bay on your right is
called wineglass bay and just a really
picturesque setting and again with these
unbelievable rock formations and some of
this you know a lot of the the landscape
of tasmania was formed through a lot of
periods of glaciation mountains being
formed and then being covered by water
and then the water receding and so just
really carved out and diverse geography
and so it's moving to the center of the
state it starts to look extremely
different you see this low-lying brush
and this portion of the state which
isn't really high altitude it's very
harsh climate so we're looking at cold
damp very swampy and you can see this is
in the middle of the state where we're
not near the ocean at this point and
lots of standing water and just unlike
just very interesting rock formations
and low-lying brush but still mountains
and so these are the types of I
I have to include these types of use cuz
they're spectacular and it really just
gives a view of what Tasmania has to
offer in terms of just unbelievable
beauty and being from Oregon originally
I mean this was I'm into this this is
gorgeous and wonderful hiking and
wombats which I know I can't show
pictures of Australia without showing
pictures of its creatures and so wombats
are hilarious and they're often in these
sort of low plain areas digging holes
and being hilarious and can't they are
not deterred they don't care about
people at all they just dig their holes
and eat all day long this is cradle
mountain which is a beautiful spot in
the center of Tasmania just unbelievable
peaks and then this really interesting
vegetation we almost see palm like trees
in the center and as we move kind of
into the southwest part of the state
this is all World Heritage Area and so
really you this is all park land there's
no one who lives in this part of the
state at all it's all really unlike a
pretty amazing hiking trails backpacking
trails and this part is a damned area
which has formed this lake and this is
literally where the roads end in the
southwest and so you can't drive any
further than this if you want to
continue down into the southwest part of
the state you're looking at a 7 to 10
days backpacking trip down to the ocean
and this little guy in the front is a
spotted pole he's quite adorable Cole
hey qu oll a tiny or soup you'll
and then as we head back towards Hobart
we start to see just a really stark
change in vegetation almost jungle like
with palm trees and huge fern also
dolomite caves not dola right but all of
my caves are pretty prevalent and also
home to platypus which I never saw so I
still have no proof that they really
exist and then back to the Isthmus on
bruny island which is only about an hour
outside of Hobart and just some this is
where Captain Cook originally arrived
when he came to this part of the world
and just spectacular views and just to
reiterate Tasmania is cold for a lot of
parts of the year so this is me
backpacking and I do indeed have a lot
of clothes on because it was rainy and
chilly and so worth it as well and so
this is the view from top of Mount
Wellington which is in Hobart and this
is looking over Hobart and the haziness
that you see here is from the controlled
burns of the eucalyptus that the
firefighters were in charge of doing and
that's because the seeds of the
eucalyptus require fire in order to
germinate so but by the time the end of
the winter was approaching these
controlled burns were going almost all
the time and we're back in Hobart now
and this is Mount Wellington and again
with the dolerite pipe
uh no I mean it might just be the light
to be honest but there is like a redness
in those rocks that is pretty pretty
phenomenal and then a wall beats I can't
not show a wallaby and these guys are
everywhere and basically think about
deer and how deer everywhere in Ithaca
the Wallabies and the smaller cousins
patty melons those are everywhere as
well and on campus at the University
Tasmania hopping around and so here is
Hobart from Mount Wellington and we see
so if you were to look down in this part
this is where the University of Tasmania
campus is so not too shabby looking over
the ocean there so Hobart self has a
really rich but also very conflicting
past with a completely wipe there was a
clay wipe out of the aboriginal
population when the Europeans arrived
and so it's a quite devastating history
to learn about and then also at all of
Tasmania was a penal colony and so the
island itself was the prison and so a
lot and I would say most of the older
buildings were convict silks including
my little house that I lived in down
there in the corner that was built by
convicts in the 1880s and so just the
history is very is everywhere who
prevalent also from an agricultural
standpoint there is a rich history of
apple growing and a lot of southern
tasmania has apple orchards and just a
lot of and quince quince and apples and
a lot of interesting history involving
that type of farming and then also and
then more recently a move into grapes so
I was based at the University of
Tasmania and I worked primarily with
Cathy Evans who was based at the Hobart
campus but I also worked with Fiona
Kerslake who was a junior research
fellow up in launceston in the northern
part of the state and so I kind of split
my time between the two of them but was
primarily based that's my lab was at
in Hobart at the Utah's campus and I
worked a lot with Cathy so the major
Biddle cultural areas in Tasmania I've
highlighted them here but the three that
i worked in primarily where the coal
River Valley the Derwent Valley in the
Tamar Valley and the tan Marvel you can
see up near launceston the Coal River
Valley ins of Derwent Valley down your
cobarde so this is where I primarily
split my time and in the coal River
Valley i worked with two commercial
vineyards the derwent valley with 10 and
in the tamar valley to other commercial
vineyards this was all organized by
Fiona and Cathy which I was just so
grateful that they were able to do some
ground work for me so in terms of
northern tasmania while i was there
there was a series of brush fires that
started right a couple weeks after i
arrived and persisted for a big portion
of the time that i was there and so you
can see on the left hand side that's my
view from one of the vineyards that i
was working in and you can see the
burning happening in the big plumes of
smoke and then this the orange skies at
night in launceston were from the brush
fires as well and though there was a lot
of conversation about smoke taint and
how it would impact wine quality there
was a lot of research going on at that
time by fiona actually about how the
brush fires are going to impact the wine
quality so i don't know i haven't heard
from her lately but I had heard that
people were feeling pretty helpful about
it that there wasn't a lot of damage to
the grapes in the end and then the
hobart area and Coal River Valley was
going through a mean the whole state was
going through a drought but pull River
Valley was visibly drier than whenever I
was up in the Tama or Valley Tim our
Valley lot more humid and just a lot
muggier where is a lot drier down in
Coal River
and from a viticultural standpoint I
mean viticulture in in Tasmania looked
to look very familiar to me there wasn't
a lot of differences in terms of
training systems or trellising looked
very very similar to what we were used
what I was used to be a lot of the SP
train finds the everything was irrigated
and just very familiar viticultural
techniques because a lot of them has
been brought over by Europeans
originally and so in terms of my three
research components I'm going to start
talking about just these three the
Illumina sequencing component looking at
sour rock causal organisms and then also
the environmental effects so the
question that kind of guided this the
Illumina sequencing component was at
what epiphytic microbes are present on
the grape surface so I had three years
of data on this topic from the Finger
Lakes and I wanted to also expand this
to Tasmania and so my goal here is to
understand the presence and changes in
yeast and bacteria over the course of
the growing season and how I did this
and one of the reasons that I needed to
arrive so early in the growing season in
Tasmania was because I worked in five
commercial vineyards and did DNA
extractions on grapes starting at
pea-sized berry to very early on in the
season and then took samples at
pea-sized bunch closure brazen 15 bricks
and at harvest and then using amplicon
sequencing with i TS and 16s primers to
amplify fungal and bacterial DNA so it
was a it's a huge project and
unfortunately because of it being a big
project I do not have data to show you
on that but it is going into a very
large paper that we are we're working on
and
I'm excited that the research from the
drear is going to go into a paper that
will be out next year so well I see
Lance over there so fingers crossed that
it'll be out next year so the next
question that I wanted to answer is sour
rot found in Tasmania and obviously I
already answered or spoiled it for
everybody and yes it is in fact found in
Tasmania this is an echidna by the way
he was hanging out in the vineyard and
amazing so cute so in terms of style rot
infants and incidence and severity I
took incidence Insperity raiden ratings
every five days until harvest out of
commercial vineyards in Hobart and this
was just it was a vineyard actually that
my husband was working at at the time
and he said hey we have sour rot here
because fortunately I have trained him
very well to recognize shower rod
symptoms and so I went out there and
every five days I took disease and
incidence ratings and here are some of
the examples of the first that I found
from there so and if we look at those
incidents and severity ratings we see an
exponential increase in the amount of
disease in this field and you know part
of this is that there is so little
education of these sorts of disease on
these sorts of disease symptoms and also
there are very few tools available to
growers for sour rot partially because
they're there aren't any real label
products for it especially not in terms
of insecticide so there's nothing to
target the drosophila so once the
disease starts it progresses
exponentially and we really see this is
a huge amount of disease to the point
where the grower really was dropping the
fruit on the ground underneath of the
vines and I tried to part of the
occasion was telling you don't drop the
fruit under the vine
because if the disease being spread by
drosophila the drosophila are going to
continue breeding in your grapes and
then go up into the canopy and spread it
more which is exactly what it did and so
it was an educational process for me as
well to know that you know these are the
types of measures that needed to be
communicated as well remove that fruit
from the vineyard get it out of there
don't let it sit underneath those vines
and continue spreading the disease
that's a Tasmanian devil uh just in case
you guys were wondering about whether
they were there they are indeed you
talked about them for two seconds and
then get back to science that they
somebody asked me about this earlier so
they do suffer from a facial tumor that
has been devastating their population in
Tasmania but there are several breeding
programs which have been very successful
at reintroducing resistant Devils back
into the wild and they've been doing
really really well they've had huge
success and actually I saw one while
backpacking and out on island one like
wandered up to the campsite and a little
too friendly for my liking but yeah so
they are there and they work you so we
one question we really wanted to know
about sour wat was are there the same
causal organisms for sour odd in
Tasmania as there are here and basically
what we know about that is that we
require yeast and bacteria and fruit
flies in order to cause our rod and was
that the same answer as where are those
the same causes in Tasmania and so what
I did was I washed took a wash of three
berries on each of ten clusters from six
vineyards played them out and then sent
to rest of each / sequencing
and what I found was very encouraging so
yes things are very consistent with what
we what we see in the US and in the
Finger Lakes is that yeast its present
in very high quantities as well as
acetic acid bacteria which is what we
had been crossing our fingers for but
also we found so we were very very happy
to see that the yeast and bacteria were
present in the samples and that these
are the same these are the same species
that we see here in the Finger Lakes as
well so no big surprises but also very
exciting to see for the first time that
we can tie a shower rod and Tasmania
sits however out here so in terms of
environmental factors where we were
looking at whether we could put some
hobo data loggers out into the field and
take measurements every 10 minutes for
11 days and track temperature dew point
relative humidity a whole bunch of
environmental factors and see if we
could correlate them with sour odd
symptoms and what we found at that same
vineyard in outside of Hobart where I
had the very high levels of incidence
and severity of Sarah rot is that I was
able to correlate maximum daily dew
point very well with my severity ratings
which just meant that it gave me a
jumping off point to when I returned to
the finger lakes that we could further
study the like further study temperature
and relative humidity and maybe there
was a correlation there that we wanted
to look further at and kind of
conversely in another vineyard where I
suspected there would be sour out but
there didn't end up being any we saw
that opposite trend so there was a
downward trend of maximum daily dew
point and this was sort of just a
jumping off point for us to delve deeper
into the environmental
that would be causing susceptibility and
the last component just that I think is
very important and I kind of touched on
a little bit was I worked a lot with
growers when I was down there to educate
both growers and the crews about how to
identify cell rot and how to manage it
there are a lot of backpackers down
there who work in vineyards to support
their traveling and a lot of them have
never worked in agriculture let alone
vineyard and so they're seeing grapes
for the first time they're harvesting
grapes for the first time and so there's
a ton of Education to do and also the
crew changes every year so it's a brand
new group of people and so talking to
the vineyard managers about what's our
rot and how to educate their crews on it
was a really big factor in what I was
there to do and I think it was it was a
really educational process I think for a
very great educational experience for
both me and for them just to understand
what they had available to them and what
sort of viticulture techniques they
could use when they didn't have the
spray management techniques available to
them so I want to thank there's so many
people to think but the Frederick dear
award itself as I mentioned before just
such a fantastic opportunity and I
encourage other graduate students to
apply for it as well as the award
committee members kneadable select
Mervyn Peretz and Josh Sarah my
collaborators at University of Tasmania
as well as Tasmanian grape growers and
the ones i listed here were the vineyard
manager is primarily at these various
wineries and vineyards that i worked
with and of course my p.i wayne wilcox
for allowing me to spend six months to
go to Tasmania and I feel like I really
brought back a lot of very valuable data
that we're going to be able to put right
into paper it so looks looks good for
everybody so with that I will take
questions
[Applause]
yeah so the question was are there any
viticultural techniques that the farmers
are using that our effective against our
rot so that was that was tricky because
we think part of the problem was when I
went down there originally I didn't even
know if we were going to cease our run
so it was a big question mark up until
the point where I actually saw shower
rod in the singers and so I was kind of
observing their practices and seeing if
I could point out anything to them but I
think what we continually talked about
is how to loosen clusters and so leaf
pulling techniques and any measures that
you can do from a viticulture standpoint
to reduce the compactness of clusters
because that's really what does it is
when those berries are pushing up
against each other and they're forming
wounds it's an entry point for yeast and
bacteria and for fruit flies to let eggs
and so kind of reducing that cluster
compaction was a really big deal and so
primarily leaf pulling in the early
season I mean that's been the most
effective technique um yeah but you have
to be really on top of it you'll be very
vigilant and you'd be pretty dedicated
to it because leaf pulling requires a
crew I mean you can do it with a machine
that a lot of people don't have
mechanized leaf colors to just put on to
their tractors so it's very expensive
either way but it is a technique that
people have used in the past and it's
well researched and there's a lot of
literature about it but that was the
biggest thing that I could recommend to
people because there weren't and it was
all for next year right so this is we
had it even harder because I well I'm
standing there going well there's
nothing really that you can do now
except for remove this fruit from your
vineyards but next year
about leaf pulling think about really
reducing that cluster compaction to the
best of your ability so the question was
about thicker thick skin versus thin
skin varieties and whether viticulturist
SAR switching to thicker skin varieties
to avoid the disease and no not really
so the problem is is that thin skin
varieties are primarily grown in cool
climate viticulture areas because of the
ripening issue that you need to get the
fruit rice and thicker skin varieties or
more they take longer to ripen and so
it's kind of a you're in a tight spot
where you can't pick switch so much to
the thicker skin varieties because
they're going to be more difficult to
ripen so no we're not really seeing that
I think some people are at least here in
the Finger Lakes Pinot Noir is a
difficult grape to grow period it's a
it's it's difficult and it has trouble
right thing here and then on top of it
it is very susceptible sour rot so in
talking to several growers in the area I
know that some people are just they've
had it with with you know my kids one of
those things where they're they're not
going to go through the trouble of
growing it anymore to then have it you
know get sour rot a week before harvest
and then not even be able to harvest at
all so there's there's conversations
going on but at a very small kind of
micro level at this point yeah switching
and then also from from a little
cultural standpoint re grafting your
vines is a huge costly undertaking and
so most people don't have that option
it's more just managing the vine so you
already have yeah yeah so the question
was whether I have guesses as to the
sequence of events of yeast bacteria
drosophila as I drop my microphone so
yes we do have guesses so we have found
yeast on the surface of the grapes from
a very early point in the season and I
think that's the it's a generally
accepted idea in the wine industry that
there is East that is coming in on the
surface of grapes the question is where
is the acetic acid coming from thus
forming the vinegar and so yeah the
alumina is that's kind of the role there
is trying to address where this bacteria
is coming from we know that fruit flies
themselves they eat yeast they eat
acetic acid bacteria so it's on their
bodies so they are they could be
vectoring it right they could they could
be the instigators but it could also
just be on the surface of the grape
itself and there could be something to
do with the Flies something to do with
an enzyme that could be speeding up the
process or as they liquefy the pulp of
the crepe perhaps that's helping to
speed along the process and so yeah that
is sort of the that is the big question
that still has left we have to we have
to address before I can be done with my
PhD is sort of what is the sequence
because that's everybody's question and
it's my question too so we're getting
there yeah I hope to know
yeah so the question was whether the
sort of epiphytic microorganisms change
from vineyard to vineyard in different
regions and so that's the role that's
kind of what the Illumina sequencing the
aim of that that's basically that's the
name of that side of the project is to
understand whether it it changes not
only over the course of the season but
from site to site I mean the whole idea
of terroir in winemaking is that every
single site it that's what affects the
wine quality and the wines that are
produced out of there so one would think
that that would you know be affected by
the microorganisms that were specific to
that site so far we see a lot of the
same yeast at every site you know
there's there's like a top-five yeast
and that we see everywhere the questions
are whether they change in quantity and
how those are affected by different
environmental conditions and over the
course of season so I'm really hoping
that that that paper is going to address
some of that yeah oh so the question is
whether there's an epicenter for wheres
our rod originated and no I don't think
because it's not I'm not dealing with a
traditional pathogen I don't work with
you know one a causal organism that is
traditionally considered a plant
pathogen we're dealing with yeast and
bacteria which is just in the
environment so I think instead of there
being an epicenter of the disease it's
more like the environmental conditions
that give rise to the disease so it's
it's more of a question of water you
know obviously cool climate viticulture
with Center spins and varieties and
where there might be more humidity or
higher humidity and of rains near
harvest that's where you're going to see
more sour out because those are the
conditions that give rise yeah exactly
that are can do
to sour on as opposed to boost their
being an origin of the disease yeah yeah
it's a great question so the question
was about whether was you know before I
went the disease wasn't on a lot of
people's radars and so now that I'm not
there anymore what what things are in
place to help growers going to manage
this disease or or talk about it there
isn't a lot there is no extension system
like we have here I mean the the
researchers work with growers but
there's no formal system where they have
an appointment to go and you know they
have to spend X amount of time out there
talking to growers there is a active
grower community they are interested in
they're interested in learning and they
talk to each other a lot amongst each
other but there isn't anything no formal
structure available to them to meet up
and and how these conversations I think
a lot of a lot of growers that I worked
with just said well we've never seen
this before it'll probably never happen
again and I'm going like oh gosh well I
really hope I didn't personally caused
our rot for the only year that I happen
to be there but uh yeah I'm hoping that
it'll just be I think it'll just be
something that happens naturally over
time that the growers are going to have
to have those conversations because it's
the problem isn't going to go away this
is it I can guarantee it wasn't a fluke
and I think it's just going to have to
happen between themselves but because
there are so there aren't any tools for
them to use in terms of insecticide
spray which is going to be the most
effective tool that they can use so
people are going to have to get creative
but no there's not a formal structure
for allowing that to happen which is
really it's really unfortunate yeah this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu